[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
hi I'm Ian Hatton wick the director of
family the MIT laptop ensemble I'd like
to share with you a little bit about
what our semester has been like but
before I do that I thought I were to
introduce you to family as it's one of
our Mighty's newest ensembles and one
that you may not be familiar with so the
question I get asked the most of what I
talk about family is what is the laptop
ensemble what is a locked up ensemble -
and in order to answer that question I'm
gonna play a short snippet of some of
our earlier concerts before this move to
an online semester
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I shifted to a semester of online
rehearsals and concerts playing much of
the world we turn to zoom for video chat
in parallel with zoom we also created
several software systems which allow us
to send control messages over the
internet so in a family online concert
all of the audio that you're hearing is
coming from one central computer but the
audio from this computer is being
controlled by performers who may be
located at thousands of miles away
streaming to you live from st. Louis is
Jerry jay-z's a everyone this is Anita
joining from Taiwan this is in question
i Jesse calling in from beautiful
Cambridge Massachusetts but this is
Janelle Hall I'm enjoying a happy
equality of live anymore just going on
everybody
Josh for Dale calling in from Florida
hey guys this is rich Kerby I'm calling
from our lovely campus in addition we
also utilize several techniques to
enhance the online experience one of
these is sound spatialization which
enables us to play sound in a 360 degree
circle around your head
[Music]
[Applause]
we also use a variety of visualization
techniques which allow both the ensemble
and the audience to get a sense of each
performers contribution to the overall
sonic mix
[Music]
you'll witness these techniques in the
piece were contributed tonight's concert
a piece called cursors by family member
Ian cluster and myself cursors grew out
of a conversation that Janna and I had
imagining a sequence of notes as a
circle and giving each performer control
over a segment of that circle so
performers can place events within their
segments they can also see the entire
circle with everyone's contributions
we're also interested in the idea of
interacting with the cursor which moves
around the circle to trigger events what
happens if the cursor can be sped up or
slowed down change direction or even
become fragmented so the piece is an
exploration of the musical possibilities
that this creates this piece builds on
several themes from families practice
including networked collaboration and
shared control over musical processes as
in any ensemble it's essential to be
aware of how your actions contribute to
the overall musical Gestalt and much of
our rehearsal process consists of
exploring how to work together to get
the musical results that we want
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
I think I'm on welcome to this video
welcome to our virtual concert part of
it is virtual part of it is actually
real we decided that we would give you a
little sampling of what happened before
this crazy time and what we managed to
do after things got crazy so the first
thing you'll hear I got a look at my
cheat sheet here is the MIT Chamber
course is performing the Gloria from the
Bach mass and a major so its students of
mine from from MIT a select group
singing the mass of the glory from the
mass and a major I'm the director of
choral activities by the way and then
you're going to hear what we call our
vocal repertoire class and I will let
Kari Diehl who runs that class introduce
what they did and this this recording
happened after we were all everybody
zooming like crazy and then the last
thing is we did a virtual chorus thing
because we were supposed to do a musical
theater concert so we decided the group
decided as a course that they would
record one of the pieces we had been
working on which is a really fun piece
from Hello Dolly called put on your
sunday clothes
so please enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning I'm dr. kerry deal and this
past semester i had the pleasure of
teaching song repertoire and performance
which is a class that takes place in the
spring semester for the past several
years I've been an instructor a voice
for the private Emerson endowed
scholarships but this is the first
semester that I had the incredible
advantage of teaching this class live
and what a semester it turned out to be
I had no idea what I was getting myself
into
so when they came to me in early March
and said well how would you be able to
teach this class online it's a
performance class my first thought was
this would be impossible but mother
incest he happens and I rethought about
this and presented the students the
opportunity to keep going with the same
syllabus that we had already planned but
they were able to use tracks of recorded
accompaniment
so those came from either our class
pianist the wonderful Clara roux or they
came from the virtually vocal
application that Nina are wonderful
librarian procured for us in you know
breakneck speed so that the students
would have this available to them and it
works really well and in some ways I
think it actually was an advantage
because some students that didn't have
private lessons were able to practice
with tracks that they would not have had
before they would have just had to wing
it in the class so in some ways I think
it made the students even more prepared
beyond that they were excellent with
writing their timings into the scores so
that when we needed to stop and start
which was more problematic without a
live pianist we were able to say okay
start at one minute five and we're gonna
do this section again so we were able to
do a lot of back-and-forth the students
were able to sing we did mic checks at
my one got a microphone from the music
department which was excellent so we did
a little sound check the students sang
we had group discussion on zoom' we went
back and we fixed some things
one thing that was
wonderful as the students could share
their screens so they could show their
translation page and their information
page and then they could segue right
into showing the actual score and we
could highlight parts in the piano or
vocal writing and discuss that and
everyone had it right in front of them
and I think the students were really
wonderful about group discussion that
chats were filled with positive comments
Thank You Alison you were amazing
positive comments to the students back
and forth that were happening during
class time and the thing that struck me
the most besides the fact that the
students were so willing to adopt is
that I when I wrote to them over the
break I said please let me know if
you're not going to continue with the
class so that I can assign repertoire
appropriately thinking students are
gonna drop out they did not sign up for
this they signed up for a live
performance class not one student left
the class even one student who was in
Korea it was 4:30 in the morning when we
were doing our class so she had to do an
asynchronous but she would send in her
videos and then we would comment on them
and she would be able to view the
recorded classes at a later time so I
think at the end of the day I was really
satisfied it wouldn't have been my first
choice but I was really satisfied with
the work that we did in class and how
the students adapted and I really felt
lucky to have been able to teach that
class this semester that choice but good
for you for for pushing it and you did a
lovely crescendo with it as well so
let's go back to the beginning see if we
can find a little bit of that and we're
gonna jump to that part and um see if we
can make that a Val happier
[Music]
oh good I'm gonna have you do it one
more time and now I'm gonna ask you for
something else you've got the note you
don't need to worry about it can that
note grow towards that seventh that I
just mentioned rather than just kind of
being like this oh please just that like
mix that will make it seem like the
phrasing is a little bit more organic
and I think it's gonna be easier to sing
too so one more time and then we'll Joe
[Music]
okay so let's go let's start on page two
do you have a timing for time together
with time to spare so we can kind of get
into that and it was but don't sing it
alright so I'm gonna I'm gonna try two
things I'm gonna start you with an e
vowel so I'm gonna have you sing I'm
gonna have you sing some it'll be a
little weird but I'm gonna have you sing
some D some weed and we're gonna try to
see if we like the position of the e
vowel a little bit better than the a
vowel let's find out right now the a is
just a little spreading it gets slightly
fluttery time together
[Music]
okay good all right so here's that
here's the fun fact about that is that
it almost it sounds like an evil anyway
on what else is gonna agree with me on
this right it just sounds like an easier
one so now we're gonna maybe just
slightly lower your tongue into an a but
I don't want you to collapse anything
that you had that was much more vertical
and up ea8 not changing anything around
here I'm just changing my talk a little
bit and let's see if we can get the
happy medium between those two things
and you can show us your lovely
crescendo through that phrase against
time together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay Emily I had to say that was really
beautiful
I hope that felt it I know it was easier
for you - yes
you
[Music]
you
you
those world I see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see the shoes you got monocle to go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
join me ask yourself Tony masters a
positive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
March 14th 2020 was the date that the
MIT Wind Ensemble was going to perform
its first of two spring semester
concerts unfortunately on March 10th all
concert events on campus including our
concert were canceled due to health
concerns relating to the growing
pandemic one of the pieces the MIT Wind
Ensemble had prepared this spring was a
set of five Yiddish dances by British
composer Adam gorg professor gorg had
written the work in 1998 for the 60th
birthday of renowned British conductor
and educator Timothy Rhenish being that
we had one rehearsal left before the
students had to leave campus we decided
to record a run-through of the concert
at that last rehearsal on March 11th in
the hopes that the music could be shared
and enjoyed at a later date in the time
since the campus was evacuated and
remote learning was implemented the
members of the MIT Wind Ensemble have
enjoyed a syllabus that has included
private instruction in performance
transcribing composition and program
selection for wind ensembles
additionally we have had weekly video
get-togethers where we listened to music
played music related games and produced
a virtual ensemble performance video for
the MIT twenty20 online commencement due
to the extenuating circumstances around
the making of this recording the
performance you're about to hear is one
of the most emotionally charged
performances the MIT Wind Ensemble is
given I'm Kenneth famous acting
conductor of the MIT Wind Ensemble and
behalf of all of my fellow members I
invite you to enjoy three movements from
adam gorgs Yiddish dances
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
hello i'm evan Sabourin i had the
privilege this year to be director of
the MIT symphony orchestra or mid so as
we call it which up until mid-march
meant I got to spend five hours a week
making music together with a stage
crammed full of amazing talented people
most of whom one happened to be MIT
students and then the virus hit and like
everybody else we got scattered in our
case to over 40 cities in 22 states four
countries three continents two
hemispheres and like so many others
worldwide we began exploring ways to
keep making music together to keep
learning from each other to keep hearing
each other which even with technology is
not so easy to do when one person ends
up say in Missoula Montana while their
stand partner where they normally sit
right next to in rehearsal that's I've
been Wellington New Zealand so we all
got USB microphones and everybody taught
each other how to record themselves and
how to work with audio software and we
tried a few things and we settled on the
two projects you'll hear in a moment
both of which were conceived undertaken
and completed over the past two months
under lockdown with every part recorded
remotely in bedrooms basements porches
wherever so in addition to thanking the
musicians we owe big thanks to their
family members and housemates
some of them I hope are watching because
you helped to make this happen to the
pieces you're gonna hear are from very
different eras both familiar and
comforting in their own ways but also
music that we found challenging
nourishing energizing this is music by
the two bees by which I mean of course
Beethoven and the Beatles so first up is
the second movement of Beethoven's 7th
Symphony the alligretto which seems so
well to capture the moment that we're
currently living in it's straightforward
and frankly a little somber and it seems
to grow right from the beginning out of
the very act of living the heartbeat the
breath the very formation of thought and
it never leaves that reality but it
takes us on a journey that includes
immense hope memory possibility and the
beauty that even the most
moments in life can contain it also
presented us with a lot of challenges
like how do you make a tuba in Livonia
Michigan some like a trumpet in a
concert hall and how do you make a
mixing bowl from a kitchen in Naples
Florida sound like a timpani but the
main thing was how to do it all in a way
that did Beethoven justice a way that
felt and sounded like making music
together
you'll hear the results in a second and
I think the video which is completely
comprised of images submitted by the
players of where they are and what
they're doing will give you a sense of
what that all involved and after that
we'll end the evening with the vision
for where we all want to be going this
will be George Harrison's here comes the
son from the Beatles Abbey Road album
performed by the mid-south Beatles
project beautifully arranged and
produced and frankly spearheaded by our
own Isaac Metcalf who by the way will be
getting his bachelor's degree from MIT
in exactly one week lots more to say
about it all which we can do in the zoom
chat afterwards and in the meantime
thank you to the players for everything
and thanks to all of you for listening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you